morning we're taking people inside the
annual technology show
it gives us a chance to peek into the
future to see devices that may change
our lives in the years ahead
this week the new gadgets include robots
that help around the house
massive new tvs are being unveiled at
the show one big difference it's all
virtual this year of course because of
the pandemic but many of these devices
focus
on our health and activities at home
isn't that convenient
ryan cooley from cnet joins us now with
a look at the latest trends
brian before you get into it i want to
remind people that this show is where we
first saw
headphones the vcr cds portable phones
uh home computers video games there are
things that
really stay with us forever that pop up
here first and a lot of things that we
never see again
let's see what we got this morning
that's the that's the problem too much
too much of what's at ces is what we
call vaporware in the business it
arrives at the show and never arrives
anywhere else but everything i've
brought you today
has a certain concreteness to it okay
i understand there is a robot from
samsung
that can pour a glass of wine that
sounds like a keeper
yeah this in this day and age make that
too uh there's one called the bot
handy it's literally gives you a hand
around the house one hand because it's a
one armed
robot that has a very articulated arm
now that may not be new but what's
interesting here is it uses its sensors
and cameras
to detect the material of what it's
about to pick up and therefore
do it properly as opposed to picking up
a delicate wine glass and shattering it
because it's a clumsy oaf
so this is kind of a new wrinkle in this
ongoing march to say how do we make
robots
that are not just amazing but useful
many consumers ask us at cnet hey the
smart home tech is cool but
where's the stuff that will save me real
labor and time
and robots tend to go that direction
yeah i like the idea of that
tell me about the flow flow is a new uh
coming to market soon
light emitter that you put into your
nostril
turn the thing on for 10 seconds and it
delivers blasts of
carefully measured totally safe infrared
and red light
why would you do this because it turns
out that does something called photo
photobiomodulation
which will cause your nose and that area
to not have a histamine reaction in
other words it's light that stops
allergic reactions in other words it's
magic as far as i'm concerned
an invisible beam into your nose that
eliminates allergies i like what i hear
tell me about these virtual medical
exams though if you do still have some
symptoms you would like a doctor to
check out but you don't want to travel
yeah check this is this is a product
called title care we have a lot of talk
about remote health and telehealth here
at ces
as you can imagine because that's become
so important let me go to this other
camera here i can show you this device
so this title care thing you get is like
a there's a base module here that has a
temperature scanner in the bottom
for forehead temp scanning but it goes
way beyond that take this little
add-on here clip it on and now this
thing is an fda-approved stethoscope to
listen for heart
and for lung function and it tells you
on the screen how to use it
but i've got more here's one that clips
on and now it's what they call an
otoscope little tiny camera right there
you can't even see it
that is going to look inside your ear
like a doctor would and the last trick
is this which is a
tongue depressor this holds your tongue
out of the way while that
camera in there takes a medically
accurate shot of the back of your throat
and of course the key to all this is
that doctors will then
be on the platform so they can see these
things as you take the readings
making a telehealth visit way more
useful very cool and apparently if
you're bored in the telehealth waiting
room you don't have to worry about an
old grubby magazine that everyone's been
touching you could have a giant big
screen tv in your house tell me about
the
scene x this may be the most interesting
thing i've seen
in terms of television at the show so
cnx is a device you would clip onto the
top of your home television
it's like a microsoft connect uh camera
that people got to know
during the xbox uh initial arrival of
that sensor and it can tell who's in the
room in very simple ways
what it does is say i see two people or
three people watching tv
if you buy three tickets to this first
run movie you can watch it
if i see too many people come into the
room i'm gonna pause the movie and say
you've got to buy another ticket or two
so it's a way of letting the studios
say wait a minute we can actually sell
first run movies direct to home
at real ticket prices and make sure
we're not losing our shirt because you
had 20 neighbors come over
to watch a four dollar rental those
economics don't work but if you've got a
way to monitor the people that are
watching
and have a virtual box office on screen
suddenly
this idea of blockbusters direct to home
starts to make sense
all right i used to i'm used to watching
tv not the tv watching me
but i guess the future is now brian
cooley thank you very much we appreciate
it